Kit Harington reenacts his Game of  Thrones audition and it is hilarious Kit  Harington auditioning for Cassie  Lannister  Chrissy Searcy  [Music]  when you play the game of Thrones you  win or you die now if you'll excuse me I  need to have sex with my brother  in honor of Game of Thrones season 7  premiere later this week the 30 year old  actor jokingly shared his  never-before-seen screen test during  Monday night's Jimmy Kimmel Live I'd  like to see my dragons even crash the  camera and it showed off his abs I've  been accepted into the Hogwarts School  of Witchcraft and Wizardry  and adorable later in the show kit found  out he's got a pretty big fan in Jimmy's  three year old daughter Jane  [Laughter]  [Applause]  you gotta fit raising a well gee  [Music]  you